dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IIFA here this
episode has been sponsored by lambda
labs not so long ago we talked about
deepmind's alpha star an AI that was
able to defeat top tier human players in
StarCraft to a complex realtime strategy
game of course I love talking about a
eyes that are developed to challenge pro
gamers at a variety of difficult games
so this time around we'll have a look at
another major milestone open AF 5 which
is an AI that plays dota 2 a multiplayer
online battle arena game with a huge
cult following as this game requires
long-term strategic planning it is a
classic nightmare scenario for any AI
but open AI is no stranger to dota 2 in
2017 they showed us an initial version
of their AI that was able to play one
versus one games with only one hero and
was able to reliably be dandy a world
champion player that was quite an
achievement however of course this was
meant to be a stepping stone towards
playing the real dota 2 then in 2018
they unveiled open AI 5 an improved
version of this AI that played five
versus five games with a limited hero
pool this team was able to defeat
competent players but was still not
quite at the level of a world champion
human team in a one-hour interview the
open air research team mentioned that
due to the deadline of the International
event they had to make quite a few
concessions and this time several things
have changed first they didn't just
challenge some local team of formidable
players
no no they flat-out challenged og the
reigning world champion team an
ambitious move that exudes confidence
from their side second this time around
there was no tight deadline as the date
of the challenge was chosen by open AI
let's quickly talk about the rules of
the competition and then see if open
areas confident move was justified these
learning agents don't look at the pixels
of the game
and as a result they see the world as a
big bunch of numbers and this time
around it was able to play a pool of
seventeen heroes and trained against
itself for millions and millions of
games and now let's have a look at what
happened in this best of three series in
match 1 right after picking the roster
of heroes the AI estimated its win
probability to be 67% so it was quite a
surprise that early on it looked like
open a eyes BOTS were running around
aimlessly over time we found out that it
was not at all the case
it plays unusually aggressively from the
get-go and uses buybacks quite liberally
at times where human players don't
really consider it to be a good choice
these buybacks resurrect a perished here
or quickly but in return cost money
later it became clear that these BOTS
are no joke they know exactly when to
engage and when to back out from an
engagement with the smallest sliver of
health left I will show quite a few
examples of those to you during this
video so stay tuned a little less than
20 minutes in we had a very even game
one if anything open eh I seemed a tiny
bit behind and someone noted that we
should perhaps ask the bots what they
think about their chances and then the
AI said yeah no worries
we have a higher than 95% chance to win
the game this was such a pivotal moment
that was very surprising for everyone of
course if you call out to win with
confidence you better go all the way and
indeed win the game right right and sure
enough they wipe out almost the entire
world champion team of the human players
immediately after they've got two more
kills seven jerax fall a third as well
that they sniped down no-tell right up
the high ground with their bow it has
the yo sceptre controlling an ax
and then noted you know what remember
that we just said forget that we
estimate our chances to win to be above
99% now and shortly after they won match
number one can you believe this this is
absolutely amazing interestingly one of
the developers said that the AI is great
at assessing whether a fight is worth it
as an interesting corollary if you
engage with it and it fights you it
probably means that you are going to
lose that must be quite confusing for
the players some mind games for you love
it
at the event it was also such a joy to
see such a receptive audience that
understood and appreciated high level
place
on words to match number two right after
the draft which is the process of
choosing the heroes for each team the AI
predicted a win percentage that was much
closer this time around around 60% in
this game the AI turned up the heat real
fast and said just five minutes into the
game which is nothing that it has an
over 80% chance to win the game and now
watch this early in the game you can see
a great example of where the AI just
gets away with a sliver of health look
at this guy
- immediately kid and they will find the
follow-up wrap around kill on - towards
him at least they're trying but with
that walk right out he's able to run
away another fisher comes out surely
this kills gonna be there but no a stun
from the span holds back the shaker and
he feels out on 30 HP opening i gets out
of there with this man they cannot get
that kill oh gee look at that this is
either an accident or some unreal level
foresight from the side of this agent
I'd love to hear your opinion on which
one you think it is by the nine and a
half minute mark which is still really
early opening i-5 said yes we got this
one - over 95%
here you see an interesting scenario
where the AI loses one hero but it
almost immediately kills two of the
human heroes and comes out favorably at
which point we wonder whether this was a
deliberate bait it pulled on the humans
from no tail
they'll kill up the crystal maiden but
open AI 5 / diving past the town doctor
was tough to spend coming back in on
minimal HP to through that style secure
the kill as opening eye again getting
the favorable trade another tower taken
they are playing at a ferocious speed
here in the second game by the 15 minute
mark the human players lost a barracks
and were heavily underfunded and
outplayed with seemingly no way to come
back and sure enough by the 21 minute
mark the game was over there is no other
way to say it this second game was a
one-sided beatdown game 1 was a strategy
back and forth we're open AI 5 waited
for the right moment to win the game in
a big teamfight we're here they
pressured the human team from the get-go
and never let them reach the endgame
where they might have an advantage with
their picks also have a look at this
looking to play a full power yeah it
just looks fantastic I wondered I mean
ever for stuff it's a skill it's worth
so much and I'll get a be doing this
VIPRE will not die and real the final
result is tu-204 open AI in the post
match interview no tell one of the human
players noted that he is confident that
from five games they would take at least
one and after fifteen games they would
start winning reliably very reminiscent
of what we heard from players playing
against deep mines AI in Starcraft 2 and
I hope this will be tested however in
the end he agreed that it is inevitable
that this AI will become unbeatable at
some point it was also noted that in
five versus five fights they seem better
in planning than any human team is and
there is quite a lot to learn from the
AI for us humans they were also trying
to guess the reasoning for all of these
early buybacks according to the players
initially they fled out seemed like
misplace perhaps the reason for this
instant and not really great buybacks
might have been that the AI knows that
if the game goes on for much longer
statistically their chances with their
given composition to win the game
dwindle so it needs to immediately go
and win right now whatever the cost
and again an important lesson is that in
this project open AI is not spending so
much money and resources to just play
video games dota 2 is a wonderful
testbed to see how their AI compares to
humans at complex tasks that involve
strategy and teamwork however the
ultimate goal is to reuse parts of this
system for other complex problems
outside of video games for instance the
algorithm that you've seen here today
can also do this but wait there's more
players after these show matches always
tend to get these messages from others
on Twitter telling them what they did
wrong and what they should have done
instead well luckily these people were
able to show their prowess as openly I
gave the chance for anyone
in the world to challenge the open AI
five competitively and play against them
online this way not only team og but
everyone can get crushed by the AI how
cool is that this arena event has
concluded with over 15,000 games played
we're open AI five had a 99.4% win rate
there are still ways to beat it but
given the rate of progress of this
project likely not for long
insanity as always if you're interested
in more details I put a link to a reddit
AMA in the video description and I also
can't wait to pick the algorithm apart
for you but for now we have to wait for
the full paper to appear and note that
what happened here is not to be
underestimated huge respect to the open
AI team to OG for the amazing games and
congratulations to the humans who were
able to beat these beastly bots online
so there you go another long video
that's not two minutes and it's not
about a paper yet welcome to two minute
papers if you're doing deep learning
make sure to look into lambda GPU
systems lambda offers workstations
servers laptops and the GPU cloud for
deep learning you can save up to 90%
over AWS GCP and edger GPU instances
every lambda GPU system is pre-installed
with tensorflow
pi torch and caris just plug it in and
start training lambda customers include
Apple Microsoft and Stanford go to
lambda labs calm slash papers or click
the link in the description to learn
more big thanks to lambda for supporting
two minute papers and helping us make
better videos thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time